[Music]  Kim and Kourtney Kardashian are heating  up Mexico the sisters are still soaking  up the Sun on their girls getaway for  Kourtney's birthday on Wednesday the two  Mama's were spotted rocking matching  silver bikinis putting their crazy fit  figures on full display Kim in court  have not been shy about flaunting their  bikini bod throughout the trip just one  look at their Instagram or snapchat  stories and you think you're looking at  a swimsuit catalog kourtney who is  celebrating her 38th birthday has been  documenting the trip with her gal pals  aka the Calabasas mom crew so where's  Chloe well she's back at home  pulling anti duties watching rain  you